it's always seem to me that this we used
to be the motivation for my LSD taking
it seemed to me that you could sit down
in a room with someone and begin to this
is maybe what I'm trying to do with you
but we never get there sit down in a
room with someone and begin to have a
conversation that would take it apart
take it apart and leave no nothing there
you know at the end no guru no method no
teacher and no nothing else either I
think that the world is held together by
a misunderstanding and that if you could
overcome that misunderstanding it would
just fold up and deconstruct and that in
a sense this is what the concept of
enlightenment is I think it's a it's a
series of insights or thoughts or
revelations one which projects forward
into another which leads you to just say
oh it's not this and it's not that and
it's not this and they're yeah well I
guess the myth the mundane plain is the
misunderstanding it's and I guess them
then if we analyze the mundane plane we
see what constitutes the
misunderstanding a belief in
three-dimensional space and time a
belief in the finite life of the
organism and then the rupture of the
mundane plane leads to this kind of
platonic super space where there seems
then to rest incontrovertible truths
they are not truths approached by logic
and argument they are self-evidently
true so they're either true for you or
they're not true
and shamanism then sort of views all
this very optimistically takes the
existence of this trans mundane world as
a higher world a world in which healing
can be done and the the community can be
made to cohere and and the shaman is it
is essentially a technician wiring and
repairing and moving behind the board of
culture keeping all these lines open and
and together is that where your interest
lies yes I see so apparently it seems to
me that it looks like mind is something
that if we were to make an analogy it's
somewhat like sulfur in that sulfur has
this weird quality of having two melting
points you you know you have solid
yellow sulfur and you heat it and it
melts but then you keep heating it and
it turns back into a solid and you
continue heating it and it melts again
this is a curious property of sulfur but
not magical the human mind seems to me
to be like that it's something that in
the mundane plane it has collapsed down
into a tool for threat detection and
social account keeping basically but
when you go alone or with your nearest
and dearest to wilderness or places
where you feel secure and you perturb
the chemical foundations of
consciousness then this is the
equivalent of heating the sulfur and lo
and behold a new geometry is cast out of
the fluid mercury of the
of the psyckadelis eyes mind and I think
I said this morning I really favor a
geometric model I think that the shamans
power comes from the fact that the
shamans really are seeing things from a
higher dimensional perspective that
that's not a metaphor or an analogy that
that's the voice of mathematics speaking
and because I as I analyze you know the
history of biology and higher animals
and culture and so forth what I see as a
continuous theme from the very beginning
is the conquest of dimensionality life
conquers dimensions life begins as a
fixed slime in one place with no eyes no
ears no nothing and it evolves tactile
awareness then it slowly becomes through
the sequestering of pigment sensitive
cells onto its surface it acquires the
notion of a gradient of light and
darkness and then through the formation
of lenses it's able to stabilize an
impression of the exterior world it
evolves progressively with more advanced
forms of locomotion eventually it
evolves memory and complex cognitive
interior maps for anticipating the
future this is a description of a
strategy for the conquest of
dimensionality and I think really the
shamans are the people among us who
represent the next evolutionary level
there are people who are who have
learned to do what we can't do to come
and go from hyperspace whatever it is an
informational super space that exists
inside the psychology of the individual
and the group that we candy
see because we're materialists fixated
on the topological surfaces of the three
dimensional manifold which is only one
level in the onion of reality these
shamans have moved over to another level
but I think they are the paradigm for a
new authentication of the human of the
human experience and it's all about
experience this is what we clearly have
wandered too far from we are too in our
heads the consequences of a phonetic
alphabet monotheism modern science Greek
aesthetics yada yada yada is just to
move us too far from experience and so
then this compensating a thing is coming
back in and the shaman is the
paradigmatic figure and when you analyze
what shamanism is the psychedelic
experience is revealed to be the seeming
qua non of this lifestyle
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you